with a game review resembling that of a
rainbow Beyond The Plum machine
miraculously defended against a
whirlwind of opportunities by dingley
Wren and achieved a draw game 8 started
off with the nimso Indian defense while
nepo Castle ding bravely kept his King
in the center then all of a sudden nepo
made a huge blunder
wait wait
I told you I told
you on the hunt for the win it looked
all but lost but NEPA was able to Bluff
his way back into the game with a
Perpetual idea that wasn't actually
there ding chose the safe route and it
missed the win but he's back in the game
he bluffed him the eval bar was like
that of a heart rate monitor with the
amount of missed wins for ding NEPA was
a stone wall with his defense ding
shakingly made a move to gain extra time
with just four seconds on the clock
after the missed chances the game was
equal and